this is the second
longest running race on the continent
now most cars are going to run
on gasoline this car the bentley
continental gt3 is going to run it on
biofuel
[Music]
so why is pikes peak so iconic i mean
it's a little obscure
but it's a big deal i think it's the
adventure and the challenge
you you can go to a traditional race
course and your targets are almost going
to be the same all the time
you've got loads and loads of
information
you you come here and you're not just
challenging the course you're
challenging the weather patterns and
everything
it's a risk factor if you're going to
get rewarded by
what the weather is going to give you um
but if you get it right and you've done
your homework as we have done and
proved to be so fast in practice
if everything goes right on race day the
reward is
unparalleled to any event in the world
tell me what this runs on this is a very
special type of fuel it's not gasoline
yeah this is a biofuel that we're
running here and it's part of you know
the green
touch element that the program has been
born from
um you know with the future of the
automotive industry going to
electric this is an alternative for any
standard combustion engine car
that currently exists you would have
seen last year that we announced our
beyond 100 strategies so
as a brand we really brought into a
renewable future
we also recognize that it's going to
take quite a few years you know
for the world to develop and for you
know battery electric cars to become you
know really
commonplace and usable etc so we see
um renewable fuels as an alternative
that could be used you know in parallel
with electrification um as a way to
allow both
you know the customers are buying our
cars today cars like the w12 or the v8s
to continue to use these cars
as well as customers who've had their
cars for many years and what a renewable
fuel does is it
it allows you to to basically you're
recapturing co2 from the atmosphere
whether you go via you know bioethanol
or whether you go by a property or to
capture like a real e fuel
it allows you to to generate a fuel that
that is not bad for the environment
and so we started to look at that and
we're really using this as a bit of a
test bed and a launch of that strategy
for bentley so
tell me specifically about this car
what we've done is we've taken a
standard gt3 race car
and then we've we've upped that a little
bit in the regs here you're a little bit
more downforce so we've got about a
30 increase in in overall downfalls from
this car
you know really mixed up against what
the regulations allow you to do
and then we've done a lot of work on the
engine particularly to allow it to run
well in this type of environment so the
real challenge here
is to be able to get your power both at
the start and then right at the top as
well and so we're talking what elevation
change
yeah it's a good six thousand feet of
elevation change
and yeah that's a particular challenge
for a you know for an engine so we've
done some work on the
on the engine we've added some more you
know some more injectors and a bit of
water injection as well
and that enables us to keep it cool and
keep it running all the way to the top
does the biofuel make any difference in
the way that the car
handles accelerates drives
there was some small mapping things
because this is a race engine
that the engine calibrator had needed to
do but outside of that the performance
of the engine there's zero loss it's
absolutely amazing
it depends on the specification of the
fuel so like with a standard fuel you
can specify fuel and you can blend them
up to get the performance that you want
so of course pike's peak is very special
your high altitude you're running a
turbocharged car here
so we're looking for a fuel that we can
blend up to be a race fuel
but still with a very high percentage of
renewable content in that and that's
really the challenge for
the challenge for this and then yeah as
time progresses we think
we'll see that we'll be able to get
fuels that are blended to match what you
want
in your road car as well i love that so
the idea is
potentially this fuel could be run in
any bentley on the road
the ideal for us eventually is to have a
fuel that is a plug and play
to your standard fuel specifications and
obviously for a for a racetop car you've
got different types of fuels
so at the moment we've been testing both
in the in the road car side and then the
in the racecar side you get different
blends of fuel and you know different
sources and
um you're depending where it comes from
you can get certain percentages of
renewability
and you know as that technology evolves
you know we think it's a great
opportunity for people to be able to run
their combustion engine cars
and still be good for the planet okay so
what's next for bentley that's an
interesting question
because you know whatever we do from a
motorsport side we really wanted to be
part of our
of our beyond 100 strategy so we're
looking at various options you know for
motorsport in the future
um and also for you know for our road
cars as well so
there's lots of there's lots of
opportunity working really hard on you
know on electrification we've got some
really fascinating cars coming in next
in the next few years so look out for
them and there's a broad spectrum of
what bentley can do and this is really
trying to demonstrate that bit more
aggressive out the edge of what bentley
is it's not just the queen
it's also about racing we can go from
that complete absolute luxury into the
spectrum
right up to you know the sporty unit
we've got a heritage in in motorsports
and we want to show
you know i want to show everybody that
we can cover that whole breadth of what
bentley is and continue to that in the
future and as we electrify and as we
go forward you know we continue to want
to have that breadth of of our brand
so from pikes peak this is behind the
wheel
for more follow us on your favorite
platforms
you